next question today is from Alice Alice
says you sometimes post cooking videos
or pictures and it seems you generally
know your way around the kitchen but
what's the silliest mistake you've made
while cooking okay this is the most
embarrassing cooking mistake I think
I've made you know how when you cook
pasta in water right you eventually want
to strain out the water and keep the
pasta so you put a strainer in your sink
and you take the water and you pour
everything into the strainer the water
goes down but the pasta stays when
you're making certain broths like for
some Asian soups you flavor the broth
with a lot of different you know
cinnamon stick and star anise and
different things but eventually you want
to get rid of the the stuff and just
keep the broth but because for me it's
such a rare thing I've gone through the
process of making a broth with you know
for fun or something like that with star
anise and cinnamon stick and pieces of
garlic and onion whatever and then
without even thinking twice about it I
will take it strain the liquid through a
strainer straight down my sink and then
I'll in left with only what I meant to
throw out which is the cinnamon stick
and the star anise and whatever else I
think I've done that probably two or
three times well how are you even
supposed to do it you have to fish it
out manually you can either take like a
sort of slotted ladle and pick up the
stuff you want to get rid of or you put
the strainer on top of a bowl in your
sink so that then when you put the water
you know the broth through it you
collect the broth in a bowl that's I
guess the way you're supposed to do it
as far as a cooking mistake though
that's not too bad I mean I've just left
the burner on and and went about my day
leaving a house and probably nearly
caused the fires one of the dumbest
things I've done in my life that's
pretty bad yeah yeah that's that's
that's certainly more dangerous than
what I did although what I did was
pretty disappointing after you spend an
hour making some nice broth and then you
just throw it down the drain the other
thing is I once tried making flan with
raw sugar because it was the only thing
I had and you want to you when you start
to make flan you want to mix sugar with
water and basically start bring it to a
boil and make a caramel out of it and I
just assume the raw sugar will work in
the same way as just white refined sugar
and it doesn't it turns out that the
white sugar is an important element as
one of only two ingredients the other
being water in the caramel so I just
made like a very strange paste at the
bottom of a pan those are the ones I can
think of I don't know maybe I there's
some I'm forgetting I think once oh
here's another one the first time I had
moved into a new place and I had an
electric oven which I wasn't used to I
was used to gas I wanted to make sort of
like breaded chicken cutlets and I was
used to with a gas range I had to turn
the gas up pretty high and with the
electric one you needed it at like
medium low the oil was so hot that I
dropped in the first piece of chicken it
instantly burned turned black and set
off a fire alarm which lasted like 15 or
20 minutes so that way that was a
learning experience I would say